I don't think that's right I mean it's I
haven't studied the India at all closely
but you know the this thing this crisis
is having ripple effects all the way
through now India you know on the
surface shouldn't be that exposed to
financial stuff but I'm being told that
there's more reliance on external and
particularly dollar financing for a lot
of corporate expansions than people
realize and so they're actually being
hit pright quite directly from the
financial freeze the demand for a lot of
goods that emerging markets export is
dropping off you know if you're not long
ago Brazil was thinking it was in pretty
good shape but all of a sudden well you
know a commuter jet aircraft right not
gonna be a lot of orders for those for a
while so all of these things hit and
then the financial stuff is spreading
not so much the major emerging markets
although Russia very much so but many of
the smaller ones and it's that's crazy
the crazy stuff that that was going on
on the eve of the crisis a lot of it is
only really catching our attention now
so I just been fascinated and horrified
by the revelation that Hungary had a
housing boom based on borrowing and
Swiss francs and all of a sudden carry
trade has collapsed all around the world
and Hungary is in trouble and they can't
cut interest rates they can't devalue
the forint because they've got all this
Swiss franc depth my god what were
people thinking but this is the kind of
thing that we're now faced with
Chinese economy have to say it's
inscrutable in any way the the what I'm
reading and then I'm just a consumer
here is that China had its own housing
bubble and so they're having their own
big problem domestically on top of
decline in exports because of the
problems abroad so all the buzz that's
coming is the China is in much worse
shape than anyone really thought was
possible